what's in it for women we've already
spent more money than you by just
putting our makeup on we're in danger
like what's in it for us so then all of
that plus this man is a pharmacist the
pharmacist tried to give me a coffee
date on a Friday Saturday a surgeon took
me to a beautiful dinner with a view the
next day after that this other man took
me to this food event
where yeah okay some of these just take
them out for coffee days and you just
saw why this nasty ass y yo this nasty
ass went on like three to four back to
bag dates talking about spend money on
me yo she got every dude who's
in the area subsidizing her meal plan
that crazy so one of my rules is I
don't do coffee or drink dates now I
understand that some women like this or
prefer this it works for some people if
you like it I love it this video is not
for you keep scrolling
however for me as for me and my
household we're going to have higher
standards started like a lot you what
she said higher standards so women who
accept coffee dates or small drink dates
but I think doing something that's a
little bit maybe lower commitment it's
both better for the men cuz they don't
have to feel used cuz men are going to
be pay mhm and it's better for the women
too because if you're just at a coffee
date it's easier right if you go up on
the date and then gret you can leave at
short amount of time um the guy doesn't
have anything can hold over you and it's
a little bit more of a casual setting
where you can feel it out especially if
you don't know each other you're meeting
from online dating it's a good way to
just start so yeah I don't know she's
saying higher standards not going to lie
everything about this girl off the top
based off body language and everything
give me difficult Vibes but I could be
just being
prejudiced you look difficult me and my
household we have higher standing that
looked difficult to
me be honest but where's the standard
though is that what we're talk is that
what we is that maybe she doesn't talk
like that all the time maybe it's just
for videos but if she talk if I'm on a
DAT with a girl and she's like listen so
today I was just moving through work
you're not doing
[Laughter]
that go bad you're not doing
that sometimes I just feel like you I'm
to be doing
this I don't know Spider-Man you're
not doing all this I'm somebody who's
lowkey when someone's like that much
energy it's just like boy I've been on a
DAT with somebody who yells like just
like they just talk super loud the whole
time I was looking over my shoulder cuz
I'm like I feel like everyone's part of
this conversation I feel like you're
broadcasting I'm talking you know what
I'm
saying yo why I'm broadcasting over
there so
like I don't know that girl over there
so
y broadcasting
like it's the news nobody know
yeah that any that's too much talking in
sky and I'm going to read it to you
because we've been talking for a couple
days and he started talking about
meeting up so he said we should get
together over some pear and Ley
cocktails soon and I said that's really
sweet sorry any grown ass man
saying parent Le cocktails girl me
what's wrong with parent Lei
cocktail that sound fr as I've
never heard of grown a pear is a fruit
and a Lee is a fruit yeah yeah have you
ever said that to one of your
girlfriends of course not but that's
what you that you you drink uh
Soju yeah yeah but I don't be like let's
get the grape so and get and get
toasty he didn't say all that never
heard of a grown ass man being like girl
let's go get some fruit cocktails and
hang you know it too that just so
weird oh you know what maybe I'm bugging
maybe you buing but it's just
maybe I'm bugging okay maybe what did
you do bit maybe it's me okay bad
I want you guys to leave a comment down
over there okay leave a comment this
and let me know what you
broadcasting why you broadcasting calm
down Hey listen I just want some par Le
cont you know what no I think you just
you ya to
something you just created something the
broadcasting is should that's a new alum
prach thing made by Abba just note the
date when a girl okay listen what I'm
she's
broadcasting these are antennas and
she's broadcasting I'm I'm don't want to
real that cuz that's good well rayon is
a earbud company yeah they do wonderful
products and wonderful earbuds for
everybody's taste it's very comfortable
it doesn't move it doesn't budge I use
it everywhere when I do sport I use it
when I'm on the plane when I'm traveling
but also when I'm cooking when I'm
throwing down in the kitchen now I'm
about to throw down in the kitchen and I
have them on right now it doesn't show
but I do have them on they're so
comfortable and they're Sleek yeah
they're right there they won't even
budge and the quality like I said is
amazing with over 32 hours of battery
life 78,000 F star reviews and the new
introduction of raycon home and
Powertech there's a lot to celebrate I
don't know if you heard but it is
someone's birthday it is uh rayon's
birthday and rayon wants to thank you by
giving you 20% off everything off the it
you can go on byon right now by
recon.com slaba and you're going to get
with the code birthday you're going to
get 20% to 40% website wide so check
that out go on ron.com
Abba and get you things today cold
birthday go shorty said we should get
together over some pear and leey
Cocktails soon and I said that's really
sweet but I prefer dinner I like to get
get dressed up now I always try to say
it nicely because I don't want to be
like I don't accept drink dates like you
don't have to be mean you don't have to
be you can you can be nice about it but
I always just say I prefer dinner
because I like to get dressed up and he
said I see what type of places do you
have in mind so I sent him a list of
places that I've been like wanting to
try all sorts of different budgets okay
it ranges from like medium to a little
bit higher all different locations
around the city so he can choose like
what works for him you know timing and
budget wise so I sent the list places he
says these places sound really nice I
think it'll be fun to get to know each
other over some nicer dining options
here it comes though but I wanted to let
you know up front that if we were to
meet at one of those places I'm
comfortable splitting the check I
usually will do drinks or something on
the simpler end for the first Meetup to
see if there's a connection first so my
thing
is I don't like the coffee or drink dat
because they're trying to audition you
to see if you are wor worth an actual
dinner this is the
thing my
girl you don't like the simple drink
because it's like if they're auditioning
you if to see if you're worth an actual
meal in the
meantime you're not taking those simple
drinks because you want the the the big
meal to audition
them
this girl is difficult the guy came back
with a very sensible response where he's
like I want to see there a connection
before I make any more of a financial
investment I know men the number one
thing men are judging you off of is your
looks right when they when they see you
they meet you they're going to be like
okay how beautiful is she is she put
together do I find her attractive right
that's the number one thing your
personality may come second sure but the
first thing is how you look right so
with that in mind if she says why I want
to go to dinner so I can look my best
she's going to say that take all your
she's going to say that and
get the out she's going to say that
she's going to say that she's going to
say that's where this is going she's
going to say exactly she's going to say
that hey all the charitability I gave to
her throw it in the trash right so with
that in mind my nars's radiant creamy
concealer costs
$32 okay why would I put on a full face
of expensive makeup do my hair make sure
my nails are done make sure there's no
hair on my body and then come and spend
two hours of my time talking to you for
an $8 coffee or a $16 cocktail be o soap
for real let's take it even deeper when
women go out with a man that they do not
know they take a huge risk men are crazy
okay do you watch the news like one why
would you spend so why would you want to
spend so much time then then take a
d what bro I thought this girl was going
to go low the went to the
flow to the
window to the floor she started
bringing up how much she spends on
herself like that's a reason for why men
should spend she did that old school
like men should pay cuz I do my nails I
do my
listen okay I'm G say this to you guys
ladies all right I'm G say this once and
don't ever bring this dumb
to me again we ask you on the dates so
we're probably going to pay for the
dates 95% time I've accepted it I don't
and moan about it I don't complain
I ask a girl out I pay for the date it
is what it is okay but if any girl comes
like yeah you should pay and I'm like
why the start they makeup you know
how fast I'll just skip out on the check
and bounce on this don't insult me
we have a social convention is a bit
but men pay it's okay men have
accepted it for the most part don't
justify it and act high and mighty cuz
your face cream cost 32 bucks I didn't
ask you for the face cream we pay for
haircuts 45 bucks gym memberships all
the other stuff cologne things we pay
for stuff too well we going to start
tabulating stuff cuz I know some dudes
who spend more on their looks than some
women what do you mean you going to
start paying we're not going to no you
won't we're not going to call not going
to count my whip we're not going to
count my whip cuz I pick you up we're
not going to count my whip what about
the gas cuz $32 plus hey $32 on your on
your face well my whip is more than that
in gas and the Whip and my clothes and
my cologne am I no let's not let's not
play this all those things my whip the
gas I put it in the cologne I wear
whatever that's all my decisions yep the
makeup and the cream that you put on
your face is yours doesn't matter let's
not put that in the equation it's so
funny to me because women use their
financial uh like the monetary
investment they've made in their looks
to justify why men should pay for the
date and then there's a men out there
who justify why women should put out on
the first date because of how much money
they've invested in the first date
meaning how much they paid for the
dinner paid for all this other stuff
it's like yo I just spent like 200 bucks
on this dinner and picking you up like
you're not going to throw me no
and we like how dare you but you ladies
are going to use Financial justification
for why men should spend money on you
like let's not do that y'all don't want
to make this sound transactional
but you come across as pigs or kind of
I'm going to say the word
because it is a bit horish when you
mention money and how much you've
invested in your looks you come across
as a then that's fine if that's
what you want to do but don't get mad
when someone looks at you like that but
that's a transaction right there like I
I don't I don't I actually do not give a
I'll go even a step further okay
we're talking all this about like oh wh
this women who always some oh when I
look good I do it for me when I look
good when I go to the gym I do it for me
when I put on this face cream and I do
my hair I do it for me don't bring it up
for a date but then once you get on a
date all of a sudden it's for the man no
it's for you so what you would have you
if if there was no guy there and you
going to the restaurant you would have
showed up like a bum no it's for you
when you go out to a bar with your
ladies do you look like a bump npe do
the ladies have to pay you do it when
you go out you look good because you
want to be in Social settings looking
good thank you yall look great we
appreciate it but don't make us have to
pay and subsidize your I I
don't know this one irks me it's
entitled it's Brady and it's
hypocritical that's want to say
that sound like a I love me some
but I like me some self aware
and self- admitted I
respect those not the ones who want to
be and then act like they not
horse don't act like you better you in
the same boat so let's pay you brought
up the money I got the case men are
crazy okay do you watch the news like
one in five men are violent he could un
alive you he could RP you he could shock
you he could harass you if he feels like
it like it is very dangerous extremely
dangerous when you go out with a man you
have to share your location with your
mom and your friend you have to send a
screen recording of his hinge profile
and the conversation that you guys had
so that if you go missing they have
context you have to text your friend
every half an hour while you're with him
to let her know that you haven't been
beheaded you have to take an Uber so
that he doesn't know what kind of car
you have and just in case he's crazy and
then when you get home you have to text
somebody to tell them that you made it
home alive men aren't doing that they
don't have to worry when they meet a
woman that they do not know that their
lives will be in danger quite the
contrary
men benefit from just being seen with
you in public okay if you are beautiful
poised well dressed it reflects well on
him people look at him and you and they
think oh wow he must be the man oo he
probably has money you know what he's
probably a good guy if he can pull her
and this is especially so if you are
more attractive than him if he's fugly
or he's overweight or he's short they're
like oh yeah he must have money in order
to be able to pull a baddie like that so
my thing is like what's in it for women
we've already spent more money than you
by just putting our makeup on we're in
danger like what's in it for us so then
all of that plus this man is a
pharmacist you're you're you're
auditioning my girl you're auditioning
that's what you're doing you're
auditioning the dude but you don't want
to do that you don't want that to be
done to you forget the floor this
is underground she and know a whole cave
subterrain she talking about it reflect
a whole ass fossil
listen you just basically made yourself
out to be some kind of trophy but I also
say something else ladies benefit from
having a man beside them
too yeah go to social events with a man
on your arm versus when you don't a man
that look good yeah mhm a man that's
well put together a man that got money a
man that's known stop yeah you don't
think a lady want to be on a being like
Oh my date uh he's a pharmacist ain't
you ladies bragging about who you go on
dates
with cuz you want to look at I'm going
to act like her you want to look good so
you want to date with a pharmacist you
want to be able to brag to your friends
that a pharmacist took you out to dinner
hi Stacy hi how you do social oh this is
my friend Marcus what you what do you do
so what do you do Marcus and she like
tell them what you do difficult tell
them what you do the pharmacist
ooh and then she looks at her friend uh
pharmacist stop and I'm not even it just
goes I'm not saying one is better than
the other it goes both ways if listen
you guys have to realize at some point
that men and women are very different
but very close to like it's just that we
are the same for different things in
different situation but if y'all do one
thing you best believe that the other
side does it too stop he listen stop and
if you want to set yourself to be like a
trophy you should do exactly like a
trophy look good and shut the up
yeah you got too many opinions for a
shiny object exactly and that's what
coming from you that's what you set
yourself out to be okay you mean to tell
me you make upwards of $150,000 per year
but you can't take me to $120 to maybe
$200 dinner two drinks an appetizer two
Entre and a dessert like and that kind
of thing so that's that's an audition
are supposed to be you know what this
girl is incredibly attractive but she
just sounds so godamn difficult you know
it's just and here's the thing about
attractive women it's like their
attractiveness will never ever outweigh
how difficult they are mhm because once
you them and been outside it's like
that is just the novelty is gone
but you got to live with the
difficultness every day when you get her
coffee she's like I'd rather have dinner
it's just like oh it don't matter how
attractive she is that just annoys
the out of you
and the response will probably be oh
well he's just saying that cuz they
broke and they can't afford yes Hey
listen yes for you yeah I'm broke if
being attractive was everything you be
able to tell me why all these
celebrities and these famous people are
very attractive don't manage to keep
maintain their marriages y looks ain't
everything if they not even number one m
I can tell you this you take Attractive
people and people who are not difficult
okay and find out which one stay married
longer it's not going to be hard to
figure out which one is which you got
that right being with someone who's
difficult that's no two Andre in a
dessert like and that kind of thing look
look men are supposed to be on their
like best behavior when they're doing a
first interaction with a woman like that
is when they are at their absolute best
so if he's being cheap now for a first
interaction he's going to be cheap on
your birthday he's not being cheap he's
being prudent he's being sensible he's
being responsible those are very
different things
it's not being cheap because you don't
want to spend hundreds of dollars on
somebody you don't know well it's being
responsible it's taking into
consideration you don't want to put much
too much expectation on the woman
because you don't want her to feel like
she owes you anything or it's a big deal
it's a very open and Leisure environment
you guys are going to go to and it also
is responsible for you because you're
not making too much of investment and
you're just being open to the person you
know the problem isn't even just what
she saying is the entitlement energy
behind that's like probably the most
unappealing thing it's how closed-minded
and narrow she is and how judment she's
being of somebody who's not even being
absurd that's what makes her very
unappealing and unattractive as a
personality makes her come across as
super ugly it's not that this guy has a
different op opinion it's not that this
guy sees it differently and we don't
Jive is that he's a cheap human
being this guy doesn't value the things
that matter in life that's what he is
that's what she's inferent from this
that's why I think it reflects poorly on
her I do not think I would hate this
video so much
now for a first interaction he's going
to be cheap on your birthday he's going
to be cheap on Christmas like that kind
of thing that only gets worse it never
gets better that is the type of man
that's going to want you to work
full-time pay half the rent when you
guys move in together do the majority of
the housework cuz he doesn't want to
hire a housekeeper um raise the kids um
plan most of the things and then after
you do your 16-hour shift of Labor he's
going to want you to be happy and sexy
for him for his pleasure that night like
that's the kind of life you're looking
at so you know what good for this man
for asserting his boundary he did it
very nicely and it showed me what his
like attitude or approach is when it
comes to dating new women and ultimately
it gave me the opportunities to choose
and I have my boundaries too so I chose
to not accept it and so I didn't I
didn't respond or anything I didn't like
bargain with him or try to justify
anything I just quietly unmatched him
because I wasn't going to let him play
on my face but like obviously if you're
on Tik Tok like this is not IR regular
discourse like this is very popular like
the red pill podcast men are always
talking about like all of these things
so like it's not uncommon like men are
trying to get away with this this days
they're trying to see what they can do
they're trying to get at you for less
than $20 okay so the pharmacist tried to
give me a copy date on on a Friday
Saturday a surgeon took me to a
beautiful dinner with a view the next
day after that this other man took me to
this food event
where yeah okay some of these
just take them out for coffee dates and
you just saw why this nasty asso yo this
nasty ass went on like three to four
backto back dates talking about spend
money on me yo she got every
dude who's in the area subsidizing her
meal plan that crazy spending
hundreds of dollars on her every weekend
the entitlement of these
women didn't she link up with none of
them no yeah she just cycling through
the hey I'm hungry hey I'm hungry stupid
coffee your coffee don't feel this B
cheap ass I need you guys to start
lining up so you can feed me coffee
bubble my gut anyways hey yo this
crazy n run
it hey man run it I'm done I'm
done bro when she the okay so he I said
no to the pharmacist but I was able to
go with thein with this with that with
run it I'm done we're good if we don't
like no we don't have to expl and to be
fair there's a bunch of women in the
comments was like girl you're doing too
much you I know would have been would
have been okay and you like what you
like it's okay if you like what you like
you want you want to go out and go on an
expensive date just say that just say
that you know thing is here's the thing
you just smack as your bro yes here's
the harsh reality here's the harsh
reality because she's attractive she can
get away with this dumb yep it is
what it is anything else you want to say
oh hell no my
God that was good job congratulations I
didn't know this video congrat
congratulations on that one myself you
trigged
yourself
congratulations thanks I appreciate
it okay stop broadcasting